efe
[Music]
you have to listen to how they are
at 14 nights ago
sport 7
is bad
ah
on the air
and nothing more
from the east
etc
in all
yes
do
later
here
this is not going to want because I stay
that  go
webber
if it's about [ __ ] I
wanted to see
j
if it's
from home web
this at
chavez yus
I've arrived
if this clip is that
time
you can
mckinsey tell
me we're here
to make it
[Applause]
routine sometimes it's easy so there's  here
r
six of seven
want you
here
66 version to read
for nothing
yesterday
parts page
after there are
ok
to return to that place you show yourself
allow
[ __ ] page
those 70 look at
both
photo strip ter
and netflix hammer
yes
special
I like
yes
the  sixers of each species
make
[Music]
I thought that no longer
why matter when [ __ ]
now no
no
i
will know
h
l
farc
I would even like to top it off
at that age
fa
cartwright
8th
and
before
athens
and
joan tomas
I don't know what it is
and
I have
honor,
that is,
ah,
in this respect,
duckling,
if you detect
cat,
then
be
the regulator, which is,
since except for
baxter cake and see a
new interpretation,
but
we are here today,
yes,
well,
ah
[Applause]
Sun,
here it is,
right, Latin text
and media
2,
wake up, Berlin,
but no.  return factors
leave me
language
and
oh
why
good
without emotion
hospital
rest fighter
there is a search pine-sol credit suisse
with that
love
the fac
here
jac
falls
once
[Music]
the day you have plenty of
the new life
and that you earn ph
will  help
if you have to touch
to see
I like them
and
it will be noticed
in building strength
the fac
I take off barn
usually is gay
you have to
endure every day I
wanted
so
day by day it heals
or person
amen sometimes
craig
grammata
the man
here
the source
with  you
[Music]
hot
excellent